zr ce bonjour un procès merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin en direct sur
rt france alors il ya ce livre blanc un
parole de chômeurs le fruit d'un long
travail pour alerter sur la situation
des personnes qui sont sans emploi qui
sont chercheuse d'emploi d'ailleurs et
pas demandeuse donc voilà oui le thème
chômeuse showmatch qu'on a repris pour
la pour un petit peu marqué mais et
c'est plutôt chercheurs d'emploi que
l'ensemble des réseaux qui travaillent
avec les chercheurs d'emploi près
préfère prendre puisque finalement c'est
la recherche d'emploi on n'est pas en
train de quémander et souvent c'est une
est c'est une action très volontaire
pourquoi pourquoi avoir participé à ce
livre blanc alors l'idée est partie d'un
ensemble de réseaux qui se préoccupait
du chômage comme le comité chrétiens
solidarité ex chômeur vaincre le chômage
ccc vaincre le chômage qui en lien avec
le réseau alerte sur justement les
personnels en difficulté avec atd quart
monde avec la seule de secours
catholique avec le un certain nombre
d'autres réseaux comme ceux ci
on souhaitait effectivement se dire
pourquoi pas parler de ce problème qui
est finalement mis un peu de côté par
les intéressés eux mêmes donc on est
parti de la parole de chômeurs
un questionnaire auprès de 300 personnes
qui ont répondu et qu'est ce qu'il en
ressort deux de ses trois salles or ce
qu'il en ressort si vous voulez c'est
d'abord que le livre blanc a été fait à
partir de leurs des verbatim puisqu'il
ya plus de 3500 choses qui ont été donc
c'est plutôt quantitatifs qualitatifs si
vous voulez et ce qu'il en ressort
surtout c'est effectivement que
contrairement à ce qu'on entend
justement d'un sondage qui a été donnée
encore ce matin où 60% des français
pensent que les chômeurs pourrait
trouver travail si il se faisait
volontaire en fait c'est tout à fait ce
qu'ils font c'est pas les quelques uns
qui fait tellement cache la forêt
l'ensemble des personnes sont en grande
difficulté est que la recherche du
travail c'est quand même constant c'est
un travail à temps plein oui oui ça
demande aussi des moyens une voiture
parfois on voit que le chèque
l'inflation est donnée aux chômeurs ce
matin sa valeur ça va les aider oui
alors c'est évident que
cette ce chèque inflation est toujours
le bienvenu si vous voulez maintenant ça
aussi puisque je parlais du de
l'arctique h la forêt si vous voulez le
dispositif de l'assurance chômage par
exemple qu'il ya it et qui a été quand
même un petit peu c'est 27 milliards en
moins je pense que le dispositif de
l'enduit c'est un milliard donc vous
voyez le déséquilibre donc on ne peut
pas évidemment ne pas dire que c'est
bien venu mais c'est vraiment peu de
choses par rapport aux difficultés des
chômeurs il ya eu cette fameuse réforme
de l'assurance chômage est-ce que ça
accentue et justement la situation
précaire des demandes alors oui tout à
fait parce que si vous voulez déjà déjà
quand vous sentez un sécu en insécurité
quand vous recherchez du travail là les
la place de travail qui ont été diminués
et ca1 quatre mois sur 24 je crois alors
qu'avant c'était beaucoup plus elle est
la période où il faut avoir travaillé
pour voilà donc si vous voulez ça ça
insécurise encore plus alors que
justement la vivre le chômage c'est pas
justement dire les gens ils foutent rien
c'est quelque chose extrêmement
difficile à vivre et donc ça les
précariser encore plus voilà beaucoup de
séquelles psychologiques également j'ai
lu une étude où les demandeurs d'emploi
était particulièrement fragile où ils
vous me demandiez ce qu'on allait
retirer un aspect sur la santé qui est
quand même très problématique
effectivement on sait bien que la
recherche d'emploi ça crée des problèmes
physiques psychologiques familiaux et
sociaux et que donc c'est un ensemble
qu'il faut traiter et c'est pas un
aspect administratif qui doit traiter ça
mais la relation l'accompagnement il se
livre blanc parole de chômeurs va être
présenté dans quelques heures pourquoi
vous fait cette démarche voulait
interpeller les candidats
alors la démarche si vous laissez entamé
depuis un an et demi un
le temps de faire cette enquête et puis
l'objectif à moyen terme c'est
effectivement d'interpeller les
candidats des différentes élections
puisque en juin jusqu'en juin élections
après les présidentielles y aura
législatives de façon à ce que cette
problématique du chômage justement qu'on
met un peu à part qui tous quand même 6
millions de français
10 millions sous le seuil de précarité
12 millions qui y aussi un certain
nombre difficultés économiques donc dans
la septième économie du monde
c'est pas un petit problème
donc si vous voulez c'était tout
simplement rappeler quelque chose qui
est à nos portes on a tous un demandeur
dans le coin chercheurs d'emploi un
chômeur à la porte et pourtant le
gouvernement dit que l'économie va bien
que le chômage baisse on aurait eu si
freud main oui mais on peut pas ne pas
mais justement c'est parce que justement
il ya les chiffres demain que nous
faisons cette conférence de presse
aujourd'hui pour faire le lien ci mais
vous attendez quoi concrètement alors ce
que l'on attend c'est que justement on
prenne un peu plus en compte cet aspect
qui a été un peu détériorée par la
localisation de l'assurance chômage par
exemple donc il faudrait quand même
qu'on qu'on se ressaisisse à ce niveau
là et on souhaite évidemment des
candidats de prendre en compte ces
différents aspects mais d'abord et puis
aussi les candidats mais de
l'opinion publique 60% qui disent les
gens il peut s'en sortir si ibos
c'est une justement alors on peut pas
les négatives on peut pas d'allant
contre cette image négative
on va pas dire c'est pas vrai et
pourtant ce n'est pas vrai donc parce
que c'est pas les quelques uns qui ne
cherche pas de l'emploi ses joues 10,2
c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt ça
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
josé d'air dans la matinale de france je
le rappelle donc ce livre blanc qui va
être présenté dans quelques heures
maintenant à 10 heures voilà à 10 heures
ce sera ou alors on est installé dans
les locaux du secours catholique parce
qu'on fait évidemment une conférence de
presse avec plateaux etc comme ici très
bien merci en tout cas on va découvrir
justement ces paroles de chômeurs que
donc il nous parlait ce matin merci
beaucoup et